there's a statistic that over 90% of
people go home at the end of the day
feeling unfulfilled by their work this
is the difference between liking your
job and loving your job you can like
your job but do you love your job and
over 90% of the people who work these
days don't and I imagine a world in
which that statistic is completely
reversed in which the vast majority of
people go home at the end of the day
feeling fulfilled by the work that they
do feeling that they've contributed to
something bigger than the bigger than
themselves
I've always been a pretty happy-go-lucky
guy but about five years ago I reached a
point in my career where my passion was
gone I stopped loving what I was doing
and I even got to the point where I
didn't really like it anymore
and for a happy person just being
unhappy was bad enough and it was this
point in my life that I made this
discovery this thing called the Y and
what I learned is that every single
organization on the planet even our own
careers function on three levels what we
do how we do it and why we do it these
are the things that we think make us
different or special compared to
everyone else but very few of us can
clearly articulate why we do what we do
and I don't mean to earn a living or
provide for your family there's a
results by why I mean what's your
purpose what's your cause what's your
belief and after I learned my Y I
literally stopped telling people what I
did and only started telling them what I
believed and not only was my passion
restored but my career and my life
changed dramatically and took on an
entirely new path with with with vastly
more meaning